the caller daddy thing oh yeah you said  you were responsible yeah i was supposed  to go on a date with sophia with an f  in case you didn't know no i know i hit  her up i was like hey can we reschedule  she was like i'm gonna go on a date with  somebody tonight superman was who she  went with interesting small world that  was going to end probably poorly no  matter what end up probably been good  they would have left anyways controversy  that ensued probably ended up helping us  a little bit when they got in that  dispute they just stopped podcasting  they didn't put out an episode for two  months put out something and then i took  their feed and i went  all these girls